I guess I don't even really know what I
think well I guess we know he existed
historically right yeah historically we
know existed he had followers he
inspired people that's document and we
know that but do I think that he lives
in the North Pole and flies around the
world one night a year giving everybody
presents no yeah I don't thinking you
kill him you become him no absolutely
not that's insane
if he dies he becomes a snowflake and
then whoever that snowflake lands on
that's the new Santa Claus yeah Wow
this is the first time I've thought
about this stuff with my adult brain
well yeah you believe what your parents
teach you into you're old enough to find
out for yourself yeah I'm just gonna say
it historically Santa Claus was clearly
a black man 100% for centuries Santa
Claus was a skinny black man until
Norman Rockwell's came along with a
Saturday Evening Post and turns one
obese old white man yeah huh well my
friend you have given me a lot to think
about this fine evening
buddy I do love our intellectual debates
yeah you have to talk about stuff you
know even if it makes you feel
uncomfortable yeah can you believe wars
are fought over this stuff honestly Sam
I can
you